HEY.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M SO SORRY.
TAKE YOUR PRESENT.
[SNIFFLING]
CRY ALL YOU WANT,
BUT I STILL HAVE TO MURDER YOU.
YOU EMBARRASSED ME ONLINE.
IT'S PROM SEASON,
AND THAT MEANS ONCE AGAIN,
I WOULD LIKE TO POLITELY DECLINE
ALL OF YOUR DATE REQUESTS.
YOU REALLY THINK
YOU ARE IN MY LEAGUE?
YOU ARE NOT.
BUT THERE IS SOMEONE ON MY STAFF
WHO'S BEEN ITCHING TO GO TO PROM
SINCE THE DAY HE WAS BORN.
♪ ♪
[DOORBELL RINGS]
DELOREAN,
YOUR DATE'S HERE.
I'M GONNA [BLEEP]
YOUR DAUGHTER.
WHAT DID YOU
SAY TO ME?
[BABBLING INDISTINCTLY]
GET OUT OF HERE, DAD.
(MAN)
OKAY, GUYS, SMILE
FOR THE CAMERA.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
[CAMERA SHUTTER CLICKING]
[HIP-HOP MUSIC]
♪ ♪
(MAN)
♪ I'M GONNA SHINE ♪
♪ I GOT TO BELIEVE ♪
♪ GO ALL THE WAY ♪
♪ NO MATTER THE PRICE ♪
♪ I HAVE TO PAY ♪
[LIGHT MUSIC]
I AM SO WET.
ME TOO.
YOU NEED TO CHANGE ME.
♪ ♪
[BELCHING]
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
IT'S 7:30.
IT'S MY BEDTIME.
[SNORING]
[SENSUAL MUSIC]
THAT'S ONE BIG-ASS BABY.
♪ ♪
LET THIS BE A LESSON TO ALL.
BIG ASS BABY
DIDN'T WEAR A BIG ASS CONDOM,
AND NOW HE'S GOT
A BIG ASS PROBLEM.
YEAH, BIG ASS GONORRHEA.